some months ago we published by on
graphics on Italian World War two Navy
commander you neo valerio borghese many
of you asked us to cover some more
military protagonist from the Italian
side of the axis alliances they tend to
get less attention than their German
counterparts and in the video today
we're going to do someone who we think
might satisfy your curiosity
today's protagonist was an Olympics
level horse rider a ladies man a cavalry
officer of three wars a guerrilla
fighter and two secret agents this is
the story of how Baron Amedeo guerrilla
became the devil commander who waged a
private war against the British Empire
in East Africa
[Music]
Bhanumati agrea was born on February rly
to an aristocratic family following in
the footsteps of his family's tradition
Amedeo enlisted in the military Academy
graduating in 1931 as a second left
tenant in the cavalry assigned to a
light Horseman regiment he impressed his
superiors with his horse riding skills
so much so that he joins the Italian
horse riding team for the upcoming
Berlin Olympics of 1936 as a young and
dashing officer with a puff of moustache
trauma Dayo quickly became known for
other successes the ladies could not
resist him and he was rumored to have
dated Hollywood actress Mary Pickford
among other celebrities but Olympic
training and romantic affairs would soon
give way to another calling in the
summer of 1935 Grillo was ordered to the
Italian colony of Libya to train a
quadrant of Spain local mounted troops
today would soon realize that these
riders whom he described as splendid
needed little training in facts he
actually had a lot to learn from them it
is not clear whether Gallade knew that
he was going to bleed the space into
battle very soon the war with obsidian
was just around the corner what he did
realize though is that to properly lead
them and earn their respect he had to
speak their language they decided to
learn Arabic by joining a local Quranic
school alongside children less than half
his age as it turned out callate had a
talent for learning languages and very
soon he was able to communicate with his
soldiers he would affect his Arabic in
the following years an ability that
would eventually prove very handy in
October 1935 Mussolini ordered the
invasion of Abyssinia following a border
incidents with Eritrea and Italian
colony Emperor Haile Selassie denounced
the act of aggression to the League of
Nations but it resulted in little action
or support from the Western powers save
furn ineffectual trade embargo against
Italy with the start of the war Gallade
could have asked for a relocation to the
mother lands thanks to his scintillating
credentials but he asked instead to be
assigned to the front after two months
of little action who was Ty Fergal a and
his space to engage the enemy at the
Battle of sellick Locklear on Christmas
Eve 1935 at that time he was suffering
from a bad bout of malaria indeed he was
so drowsy and feverish that he had to
rely on his spy sergeant do spot
incoming enemies on his behalf this is
how he took notice of an incoming
Ethiopian rifle
he was shot with his pistol this first
kill in combat the battle soon turned
into a melee and another Ethiopian tried
to tackle him off his horse you late
struck him on the head with the hilt of
his sword knocking him out cold
immediate afterward a bullet came flying
towards his stomach but fortunately for
him it hit the pommel of his saddle and
ricocheted through his left hand as the
war dragged into 1936 gleich was able to
experience firsthand the horrors and
inequalities of modern colonial warfare
official historical sauce is still
differ on whether the Italian Air Force
dropped poison gas canisters on Haile
Selassie's troops or not but we do have
gillies personal and sign witness
account he did witness at least one such
aerial gas attack during the campaign
not only did he find it a dishonorable
and inhumane way to conduct an offensive
but he also observed that in most cases
it was ineffectual against a nun
entrenched highly mobile enemies such as
the Ethiopians they found his own way of
fighting to meet the most honourable and
effective and that was a horse a sword
and a pistol when on May the 5th 1936
the Italians conquered the Ethiopian
capital of Addis Ababa
alais was not there to celebrate he had
been ordered back to Tripoli for a
delicate assignment the duche was due to
visit Tripoli and the colonial
authorities needed a skilled horse
trainer for an elaborate propaganda
stunts the ceremony of the sword of
Islam after reviewing Italian and
colonial troops atop a splendid White
Horse Mussolini would solemnly unsheath
the scimitar for the benefit of
newsreels the ceremonies meaning was to
betray Italians in Africa as natural
allies of the Muslim populations against
other colonial powers the ceremony was a
success but Golay is hand wound got
infected and worsened over time they
were sent to Naples to undergo surgery
after the operation Gilly spent some
time recovering with his relatives the
Gandharvas among them his childhood best
friends and favorite cousin was there
Beatrice people at that time they
probably should have known better than
to leave an aristocrat and a cousin
alone in the same room it very often led
to much beseeching swooning hands
kissing and other euphemistic activities
the only thing that stood between the
union of Amedeo and Beatrice as
trembling lips was a pair of expertly
groomed whiskers but those I am sure
were more of a facilitator than an
obstacle but you know we don't want to
judge different times different
habits and all that but the Reverend
jokes aside Amedeo and Beatrice felt
deeply and sincerely in love it wouldn't
take long for Amedeo to propose on the
one hand he would much love to speed up
proceedings that he would not marry her
just yet a recent law forbade promotions
for unmarried officers this was meant as
an incentive the young man to marry and
reproduce for the growth of the nation
ei was well aware of the law he stated
that his sense of on and prevented him
from marrying Beatrice straightway he
knew that a promotion to first leftenant
would follow suit immediately and to see
would look as though he was marrying her
only for that reason his plan B was to
seek another war and earn a promotion on
the battlefields and then he would marry
Beatrice which seems like a totally
rational way to plan a wedding the
occasion came with the start of the
civil war in Spain fascist Italy and
Nazi Germany participated in that
conflict by providing troops and
equipment to the nationalist side led by
Generalissimo Francisco Franco and so in
the summer of 1937 y la volunteered to
lead a detachments of Italian rdt or
strong troops into the country I should
specify at this point the Golay was
never a full supporter of fascism all
his military exploits were and always
would be related to a sense of duty
towards the King Victor Emmanuel the 3rd
and the ruling House of Savoy his
involvement in the Spanish Civil War was
born of personal considerations although
he later declared that he could not
stand the idea of a communist Spain and
he soon got into the thick of the action
assigned to an Italian division known as
the black flames he participated in the
battle of Santa and air in August of
1937 this was part of Franco's campaigns
a crush Republican resistance in the
north
he late led his men to the assault on
the stronghold of San Pedro despite
stiff resistance Amedeo succeeded in
storming the Republicans and this opens
the doors to the advance on santen death
the next big battle was to rule in the
northwest in this occasion Glade led a
squadron of Moroccan cavalry men on an
assault against a motorized column he
suffered serious shrapnel wounds but he
gritted his teeth and dispersed the
enemy units succeeding in capturing
three Russian armored cars and their
crews after eight months he returned as
battlefield promotion and a military
decoration from Franco himself but had
also received a bad leg wounds meaning
his Spanish adventure was over while
recovering in
military hospital in Tripoli he
reflected on the atrocities he had
witnessed on both sides of the conflict
in particular he was very vocal with his
colleagues about the deplorable conduct
of the Germans at the end of 1938 he
late had become good friends with a
Libyan girl
young medical students he had met at the
hospital she was looking forward to her
graduation but there was a problem she
was Jewish and the recently approved
racial laws in Italy demanded for her to
leave University these laws were a
consequence of the increasingly tight
bond between Rome and Berlin as Italian
fascism did not have an anti-semitic
component at its inception
Hilley appealed to the governor of Libya
our air marshal Italo Balbo but it was
all in vain that was another blow deltas
shaky confidence in Mussolini's
government
[Music]
with growing disgust for the political
development in Rome la asked for his
next posting to be in Africa luckily for
him in 1939 a family acquaintance had
been appointed as the new Viceroy for
the East African colonies
this was his namesake Amedeo Duke of a
Oscar a cousin of the king he had been
appointed Viceroy with the difficult
task of pacifying Abyssinia after the
conquest Ethiopian guerrilla fighters
loyal to emperor haile selassie were
still very active in 1939 and the duke
of a astor thought men like Golay were
the answer so our protagonist was given
command of a unit called the group of
Amhara bands say multi-ethnic cavalry
force which included Ethiopian Eritrean
and Yemeni soldiers led by Italian
officers Golay and Liam hores were given
total autonomy and freedom of movement
you eradicate guerrillas which had now
spread into Eritrea it was during one of
those actions that the Omaha res dubbed
their leader the devil commander after a
long series of skirmishes with the
guerrillas in the du gard du Bois region
you're late succeeded in luring them
into a clash in open flat territory
where a newest Horseman would be at an
advantage
lieutenant Golay led a charge against a
group of enemies the attack it was
successful but his horse was shot from
underneath him
yayyyy immediately requested a second
horse and charged again once more
another enemy formation was routed once
more the poor horse was shot down but
Leigh was unscathed
we like to think at this point that all
the spare horses looked at each other
nodded and decided to quietly and leave
the battlefield unnoticed while they
were doing that seized control of a
machine gun position turned it towards
the remaining rebels and wipes them out
single-handedly as a result of this
Galatia piri is awarded in the silver
medal for military valor the second
highest decoration in the italian army
Gallade colonial troops instead bestowed
on him the highest honor the nickname of
devil commander indicative of his fiery
fighting spirit and apparent immortality
in later life when recounting this event
Gallade defined himself as such the
luckiest man I have ever known
[Music]
in early 1940 they made friends with an
Ethiopian Muslim chieftain and his
efforts to pacify Eritrea and northern
Abyssinia generally Muslim locals tend
to decide with the Italians while
Christians were staunch supporters of
the Negus the Ethiopian leader
leftenant Amedeo also became friends
with the young intelligence and
beautiful daughter of the chief 10
Correa
when yeh asked her what she wanted to do
in life she replied I am going to marry
a chief and be at his side but she had
not yet chosen the chief when he left
the village with his bands he was
surprised to see career riding out to
meet him I made my choice she said you
are the chief I want to be with DA's
initial resistance was futile and Correa
soon became his lover Amedeo Soler was
understandably torn between the
beautiful Ethiopian and Beatrice back
home when on the 10th of June 1940
Mussolini declared war on France in the
United Kingdom the whole of Italian East
Africa found itself isolated from the
motherland's with little hope of seeing
Beatrice again Amedeo deepened his
relationship with Correa who would
follow him on the front lines and many
occasions the do you convey asked his
war against the British and the French
in East Africa it started well with his
troops occupying British Somaliland and
border territories with Kenya and Sudan
however total isolation meant a lack of
supplies including fuel tanks and planes
very soon they Oscar had to employ a
defensive strategy fortifying
mountaintops to resist Allied advance as
long as possible one of these
strongholds was Karin which guarded the
road to a smaller the colonial capital
of Eritrea in January 1941 the Italian
garrison akarin desperately needed to
buy some time against the advance of the
ghazal force an anglo-indian motorized
and mechanized column desperate
situations they call for desperate
measures and desperate measures require
men with courage luck and a moustache so
stiff it could deflect shrapnel on the
morning of the 21st of January the
troops of the gazelle fighting force
were taking a break brewing tea in the
gorge of kuru
suddenly a shout broke the morning
silence Savo had news g'day is battle
cry dressed in Arab clothes and riding
his favorite horse sand or the devil
commander was leading a charge of two
hundred and fifty Eritrean horsemen the
charge cut through a Sikh Redmon's
flanked a column of armored cars and
then Galla
straight towards the British artillery
Yelena's men they attacked the armored
plates of the enemy with what they had
pistols swords and hand grenades as
these troops were anglo-indian they
described the grenades as flying like
cricket balls the defenders taken
completely by surprise were cut down by
swords and shrapnel
yes squadrons rode through the column
regrouped and then launched a second
charge but this time the gazelle troops
were ready they trained their guns and
fired a point-blank range cutting
through the galloping horses but also
causing friendly fire damage as the
shells exploded amid the sikhs and their
armoured cars after a few more seconds
the horsemen disappeared into the
network of gorges of the Eritrean
landscape yeh had deadly unthinkable the
cavalry charge against a mechanized
column was it worth it while the Raiders
loss was great perhaps half their men
but the damage they inflicted gave an
importance breather to their fellow
troops keren the charger Currie would be
the last cavalry charge faced by the
British Army with many soldiers
declaring it's the most frightening and
extraordinary episode of the Second
World War
gilli knew that this was a war started
for the wrong reasons and fought with
inadequate resources he continued the
fight in to further battles kokin and to
claisen until as Mara felt Commonwealth
troops on the 1st of April 1941 two days
later the now captain Glade made a harsh
decision he would disobey orders to
surrender to the British and continue
with a war of his own a private war with
Korea by his side he gathered a hundred
of his best riders and organized them
into an effective guerrilla fighting
force his aim was to pin down in Eritrea
as many British troops as possible to
prevent them from joining other theatres
in Abyssinia Egypt and Libya the devil
commander disregarded his regular
uniform donned Arab clothes and even
changed his name to a new human identity
ahmed abdullah al redeye his embrace of
arab customs and asymmetric war against
a powerful empire would and in the
nickname of the Italian Lawrence of
Arabia after the war over the course of
eight months Killa and his guerillas
raided trains convoys and armories they
blew up roads bridges and galleries they
cut down telegraph and telephone lines
harassing British communication and
logistics to British intelligence
officers were given the task to papri
Henson major max Harare and Captain
Sigismund Reich Harare would become a
close friend of gillies after the war
but for the moment he was driven to get
rid of this nuisance he offered a reward
of a thousand pounds dead or alive but
nobody was reporting him to the British
authorities until one day an Arab
farmhand walked into the British
headquarters in a small errand gave
precise directions as to where they
could find the devil commander in his
band man pocketed a reward and walked
away while her Ari's men set off to
finally seize the stubborn cavalry men
so you might be wondering about who was
the farmhands well that was none other
than yeh in disguise he succeeded in
sending her re on a wild goose chase
while raising more funds for his cause
but his luck he could not go on forever
action after action the ranks of his
band grew thinner even his faithful
steed Sandor was captured by her Ari's
men on one occasion the farm where he
was hiding was surrounded by the British
in a Xia many disguise he jumped from a
window and simply walked away from the
encirclement
ignoring the soldiers calls to stop and
identify himself a quick-thinking
Eritrean saved him by telling the
British that the
was the death Arab peasant and to leave
him alone with the band reduced 30 men
and the bad ankle wounds Gallade decided
that he should not ask more sacrifices
from his riders he disbanded the private
army sent kadia back to her father and
decided to retreat to Yemen with just
one comrade by his side die father g'day
and if I traveled to the ports of Misawa
and paid a hefty sum to some smugglers
to take them to Yemen but the luckiest
men in the world was in for a big
surprise the smugglers did not sail
across the Red Sea but instead dumped
them on a desert shore some miles south
of Misawa the two adventurers they were
almost dead from thirst when some goat
herds appeared in the distance surely
they would help the luckiest man in the
world and his friends but they didn't
the goat herds attacked them beat them
senseless strips them of all their
belongings and left them for dead in the
desert Locke finally came knocking in
the shape of a traveling merchant who
picked up the two and sheltered them
until they recovered with the merchant
self Jala finally reached the Yemeni
port of Hadar in December of 1941 when
questions he revealed his identity and
asked for refuge in Yemen after a brief
stint in prison gray was summoned to the
capital Sanaa where he met the local
ruler Imam Yahya who declared himself a
friend of Italy the Imam welcomes g'day
into his household while the officer
made himself useful by training yars
bodyguards and even treating an outbreak
of cattle sickness buck was again back
on his side but what of the war
[Music]
in mid March 1943 news reach GA of
British plans to repatriate Italian
civilians and wounded servicemen from
Eritrea with a Red Cross ship the reward
on his head it was still standing so he
had to sneak on board and travel as a
stowaway in early September 1943 he was
finally back in Rome by now but major
Gallade demanded men weapons and money
to resume guerrilla actions in East
Africa but on the 8th of that month the
news broke out that an armistice had
been signed by King Victor Emmanuel the
third with the Allies this armistice
effectively split Italian to put it
simply fascist loyalists regrouped in
the north and continued the fight
alongside the Germans while monarchists
like Kean's the anti-fascists formed a
coalition and army in the south siding
with the Allies they was assigned to the
intelligence services of the co
belligerents performing several secret
missions in access control territory of
which little is really known one thing
is certain about this period of his life
and that's that he finally married
Beatrice in September of 1944 delays
last action as a spy it took place
immediately after the end of the war in
Italy on the 25th of April 1945 a
brigade of resistance had stolen from
fascist officials the imperial crown of
de Nagus Haile Selassie returning the
Crown's of the Ethiopian ruler was a key
to reestablishing a peaceful
relationship with that country did a
staged a daring heist to retrieve the
crown from the partisans and was then
assigned to personally take it back to
Ethiopia
he took the occasion to meet Correa one
last time during this tearful reunion he
gave her a gift not from him but rather
from his wife surprisingly Beatrice knew
everything about Kadir and was very
understanding she wanted khadiyah to
receive a family heirloom of hers a
beautiful bracelet to thank her for
taking care of Amedeo during his
dangerous adventures
[Music]
on the 2nd of June 1946 a referendum
abolished the monarchy in Italy which
became a republic Knabe decided he would
rather not be an officer in a republican
icily and retired with the rank of
colonel
his next career move would be to the
Diplomatic Service due to his knowledge
of Arabic as postings would be mostly in
middle eastern and northern African
countries which gave him the occasion to
meet again some of his old friends for
example in the 1950s he was working in
the Italian embassy in Yemen where he
was reunited with de Falla he returned
to Sonora in September of 1962 to attend
the funeral of the ruler imam ahmed by
coincidence the same night a coup was
taking place against the new imam al the
dear yeh woke up in his room to find how
the dear and his followers loading their
weapons as the conspirators approached
he helped them escape from the window of
his room as you can probably see a
diplomats life is not just all about
entertaining with pyramids of Ferrero
Rocher in 1967 da was ambassador in
Morocco during an official party he was
attending a coup was launched against
King Hassan when a firefight broke out
EA almost 60 sprang into action and
managed to save several guests from the
crossfire including the German
ambassador the West German government
awarded him the Grand Cross of the order
of merit of the Republic it is safe to
say that the luckiest man in the world
was by no means a lucky charm neither to
horses nor to Arab monarchs the same
retired official who spoke to us about
Borghese some months ago also had the
chance to meet Baron yeh he told us that
while serving in Morocco he I'd like to
take visiting dignitaries for a tour of
the market of rabbit to do so he would
disguise himself as a local and engage
in intense shouting and haggling matches
in Arabic with vendors on one occasion
gear in the vendor shouted so loud that
it looked as they they might come to
blows apparently gay had insinuated that
the vendor was the son of a dog and a
lady of the night to put it mildly
then suddenly they burst out in laughter
and embraced each other in 1975
following his final appointment as
Italian ambassador in Delhi Amedeo Gaye
and his wife retired to County Meath in
Ireland after the death of Beatrice in
1990 the former devil commander he
returned to Rome in the year 2000
aged 91 he travelled to Eritrea for the
last time in order to visit the site of
his adventure with his biographers about
you know Kelly he was received with full
honors by the Eritrean governments time
moved on and on the 16th of June 2010
aged a hundred and one after a life of
battles and charges and bullets and
shrapnel and sword wounds Amedeo GE
finally raised the white flag and gave
in to death some of our more faithful
viewers may have noticed some
similarities with another remarkable
military leader we've covered before
Adrienne carton droite both Amedeo and
Adrienne
they were both soldiers they were always
looking for another war to fight in they
were cavalry officers they suffered a
great deal of wounds but never gave up
at a certain degree of madness they
sported envía bull moustaches they went
from military to diplomatic duties they
retired in Ireland Adrienne was 29 years
older than Amedeo and died eight years
before the devil command to move to
Ireland so it's fair to say they never
met but what if for a twist of fate
these two former enemies met in
retirements and became friends we're
just left wondering what they might have
got up to you so I really hope you found
that video interesting if you did please
do hit that thumbs up button below and
don't forget to subscribe when your
subscribing hit that notification bell
so you find out when we put out a new
video also why not check out my other
channel called Geographics it's sort of
very much like this format except twits
about places and not people I think
you'll really like it if you enjoy this
stuff so please go check that out and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]